I emailed my KBMO food sensitivity and gut barrier permeability test results.
It shows slightly elevated Candida and LPS, LPS's lipopolysaccharides.
Zondulin and Oculin were near normal. I see several rife programs for Candida, including a few
footpath programs. Would you recommend just dietary changes or also a supplement? I have already
taken a binder. I also have oregano and tea tree and other essential oils at the ready. I think
this is one of those things where I can hurt if I go too fast. So how would you recommend proceeding?
Okay, so Zondulin and Oculin are different chemicals in our cells that will
change constitution which can damage the tight junctions of your gut border and then we'll
open up. So if you have elevated Zondulin or Oculin, it tells you that there's damage to those
borders and that's what's called leaky gut. So that's part of the gut permeability test. So when
you're looking at how healthy is the gut barrier, you're looking at Zondulin and Oculin. If those are
near normal, that's good. But what is worse than having elevated Zondulin or Oculin is elevated lipopolysaccharides
because that tells us that there's something that's damaged. So there's two different ways that
things get across the gut border. I mean, in wrong ways. So normally you have absorption sites for
different nutrients and things like that. But a damaged gut border will cause weakness in those
tight junctions of the cells, the epithelial cells themselves and things go between the cells.
That's if that's what's taking place, the Zondulin and Oculin will be elevated. If things are going
through the cells, that's a totally different thing and you'll have elevated lipopolysaccharides. So
that's worse. So that's one step worse. Now, lipopolysaccharides also can give us clues that there's
gram-negative bacteria present in the most common gram-negative bacteria would be H. Pylori.
So understand, there's H. Pylori tests out there. So somebody may say, no, this person at least didn't
send H. Pylori tests, but some person may say, no, I'm had tests for H. Pylori and they were negative.
I never test for H. Pylori because they're too often
incorrectly negative. So it's difficult because H. Pylori doesn't just, it's a pathogen that doesn't stay
in one place. That's the easiest way to put it. So if you do urea-brat test, which is a carbon
test for H. Pylori, it's only going to measure if you have H. Pylori in the stomach. If you do a
stool sample test for H. Pylori, it's only going to measure if you have H. Pylori in the gut.
And then you have to look at, did the person do an IgG IgA or an IgM test for H. Pylori because
those are totally different because IgG and IgA will show that you have H. Pylori at some point
in time, but doesn't mean that you have it now. IgM would test that you have it now. But I wouldn't
trust that because you still might have H. Pylori, but it's not in the gut any longer. It might have
done its damage in the gut, and now it's in the bloodstream. Well, you could do a blood test for H. Pylori.
But that can also be negative because it's not in the bloodstream anymore. It's in the tissues.
And that's very dangerous because that can lead to different cancers that is most commonly leads to,
because it gets into the tissues that lie in the vessels that endothelial cells, and it
damages the endothelial cells, and it is one of the primary causes of cardiovascular disease.
So elevated LPS, you know, so life of polysaccharides are going to be generated through
a grand negative bacteria. So H. Pylori is a grand negative bacteria, and that's the most common
grand negative bacteria worldwide. So there's other possible grand negative bacteria. One is
is Lyme disease, Borrelia, Burgodorfia, is a grand negative bacteria. But I don't have any other
symptoms of Lyme disease, blah, blah, blah, blah. H. Pylori would be my first guest, especially
if you're having gut issues. So an H. Pylori is so common. So to treat H. Pylori, yes, I would say
you see a regano, you see deglyceride, licorice, you see garlic, you see things like that are going to
be your best bet. Burberry is great for H. Pylori. And those things will be absorbed, and they will treat
H. Pylori systemically. But you still have to be working on healing the gut. And the other thing
that I would consider with healing the gut is taking buterin. So there's, we have a buterin, a product
from allergy research called buterin. It's been a little different with EN, it's a capital EN at
the end, or tributer and supreme from designs for health, they're really the same thing.
So there's a lot of good buterin products on the market, generational, health, I think that's
called they have a gut health product that we sell a lot of, but the least expensive is the allergy,
research, buterin. And usually does the tricks. That's a really good
fuel source for the epithelial cells to help heal that. But addressing the candida, also
the same things that work for H. Pylori can work for candida as well. Then there's other things
like caprylic acid and stuff that can be beneficial for candida as well. And certainly you can go
slow on it. And I would suggest that you don't want any kind of Herk's reaction because if you do kill
any herb negative bacteria quickly, you're going to liberate a lot more lipopolysaccharides.
And really a Herk's reaction is mainly driven by lipopolysaccharides. And you do have to be careful
generating too much lipopolysaccharides because lipopolysaccharides are a primary source of damage to
the blood brain barrier. So when we have damaged the blood brain barrier, that anything can get
across. And we go back to the previous question. That is what causes inflammation of the brain.
So things get in there that you don't want to be in there that are going to activate microglial
cells and cause all sorts of ramped up problems. So yes, that's how I would start trying to work
for the healing of the cut.